Enora ma chérie mon ami Enora Malagré
elle était l'invité d'Amélie Marzouk
dans son podcast intitulé miroir il y a
fait des confisans sur son état d'esprit
lorsqu'elle faisait partie de l'équipe
de TPMP et elle avoué et moi j'aime bien
elle a avoué avoir eu un moment le melon
à part Mathieu Delormeau
qui a déjà eu qui sont qu'il a eu le
melon qui sont qui l'a changé et vous
pouvez dire voilà qu'il y a des gens qui
ont changé autour de la table moi j'ai
vu des changements
oui j'ai vu des changements oui j'ai vu
des changements
regardez ce qu'a dit orage ou bien vous
avez vu voilà
moi j'ai eu un moment où j'ai perdu pied
alors je crois que j'ai eu un moment
dans un premier temps où tu prends un
peu le melon ce qui est complètement
normal parce que d'un coup on te
reconnaît d'un coup tout le monde t'aime
pour pas grand chose parce que c'est
quand même pas très utile ce que je
faisais c'était juste du divertissement
et du coup tu es adulé ou même quand tu
es détesté par plein de gens tu es quand
même l'objet d'attention donc bah moi
j'ai chopé un petit melon très rapide
parce que comme je n'ai pratiquement
aucun ami dans ce milieu mes amis m'ont
dit mais en fait tu es qui donc je suis
redescendu assez vite mais j'ai eu
direct 6 mois de Boulard
dites la vérité qui a eu le Boulard ici
et sinon je le dirai moi-même donc
Mathieu tu as toujours eu le Boulard toi
mais c'est pas pareil parce que
contrairement à un petit camarade
j'avais une carrière j'étais connu bien
de parking je faisais un million
d'audience donc si je l'ai eu c'est
énergie 12 moi ce que je veux dire et tu
parles de qui là
de moi contrairement je dis camarade que
tu es personne en fait hein c'est pas
connu tu vois description je t'ai pas
reconnu la première personne qui me
donne l'esprit donc TPMP non quoi je
n'ai pas eu à TPMP qui a le plus le
Boulard en dessous de la table Mathieu
voilà
c'est épouvantable dites-nous
mais n'oubliez pas Benhaïm elle arrive
pour animer le 607 coiffeuse maquilleuse
c'est moi Benaim mais tu as trois fiches
à lire tu es même pas capable
c'est mignon parce que tu préfères
qui a pris le Boulard dites la vérité
Guillaume dit la vérité
il existe qu'on appelle Monsieur Raymond
il s'est fait livrer un appui-tête en
cuir dans son camion
il a également exigé à son employeur un
lecteur CD dernier cri pour faire ses
livraisons en musique il est clairement
sur une plante savonneuse excuse-moi
c'est c'est tu fais des plus nulle
de ton histoire de l'histoire de TPMP
la matinale il arrive une minute avant
l'antenne ici il me regarde il dit ce
soir le conducteur de TPMP nul Cyril va
prendre une leçon demain matin sur
Virgin C'est lui c'est Guillaume
j'entends ça mais si jamais vous rigoler
tu me dis pas tous les soirs que le
conducteur est nul non c'est toi qui est
nul
merci vraiment heureusement qu'il y
avait Mathieu ah merci Mathieu
merci mon cœur franchement vraiment il a
rien dit ça va Casta très bien écoutez
dans une émission
moi je n'ai jamais eu le melon de ma vie
je raconte j'arrive une fois avec mon
camion je vois trois places libres pour
me garer à côté d'un célèbre hôtel
parisien parce qu'il habitait à côté
d'un célèbre hôtel parisien c'est vrai
ou pas dans une rue adjacente tu
habitais à côté
qu'est-ce que c'est Noël
[Rires]
[Musique]
excusez-moi je vais livrer l'hôtel là il
me dit vous pouvez pas vous garer là
j'ai pourquoi parce qu'on attend la moto
de Benjamin Castaldi parce qu'il va
partir en tournage donc les places elles
sont réservées j'avais une grande moto
c'est normal de la place 3D
tu as toujours une grande gueule
non plus jamais ça c'est du melon ça
jamais Cyril vous me connaissez très
depuis longtemps
pas du tout je t'ai vu
non
je vous dis toujours la vérité je n'ai
jamais la grosse tête contrairement ah
oui comment je compte Casta ah oui oui
vous avez peur de moi je sais que je
vous rencontre moi j'étais le caïd hein
je faisais le mot comme vous et oui
vas-y ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
quand il est arrivé les premiers jours
aussi il voulait taper tout le monde et
tout vous voulez faire le caïd il a pris
une flogie dans les couloirs
c'est lui qui a arrêté
[Applaudissements]
sa voiture
attention
et je peux te Castaldi les gars était
comme ça c'est vrai et toujours à part
vous tout le monde a peur de moi
parce que moi tu mon ami
aux mains avec un pro avec un patron de
TF1 moi c'est vrai que j'étais un peu
nerveux avant j'étais toujours un peu un
peu sur TF1 j'ai failli en venir en main
avec un un des patrons parce que j'ai eu
un petit texto de moto même un gros
d'ailleurs et j'avais 7 côtes de pété
j'avais j'avais le bras cassé et c'est
vrai que c'est pas très pro de prendre
sa moto quand on est une émission de
télévision voilà donc il m'avait fait un
peu la morale et il m'avait dit bah
regarde toi mon qui était tué avec ta
main comme ça et tu écoutes cassée il me
reste la main gauche je vais te la
[ __ ] dans la gueule voilà mais après
j'étais virtuel
comme ça on saura pourquoi tu as été
viré c'est des années qu'on se demandait
on a la réponse et je vous rappelle bien
sûr quand tu divises tu divises
quand tu dévisses tu dévisses